this thing is crazy crazy thin and light
this is the new macbook and it weighs
two pounds and also only has two ports
the macbook is just 13 millimeters thick
which means there's only room for one
headphone port and one new usb type-c
port
there's no more regular sized usb the
type-c charges the laptop but can also
be used to send video to monitors and
connect and charge other devices
apple says the entire laptop is really
meant to wirelessly connect things which
i'm not sure is very practical
the 12 inch screen is smaller but the
keyboard is still really wide to
accommodate the thinner bottom the
keyboard had to be slimmed down the keys
don't have as satisfying a bounce but i
was able to start typing quickly and
accurately
this keyboard is beautiful you will not
want to eat over it
instead of adding a touch screen the
touchpad now has new tricks it's
pressure sensitive so a strong press on
it will cause a force touch i'm not sure
how useful that will be but
you know apple force touch sounds a
little inappropriate so what's missing
well a bunch of ports of course and
there's no touch id fingerprint sensor
though when i gazed onto that retina
screen i forgot about all those things
at least for a moment the new macbook
will start at 1300 and be out april 10th
clearly there are some real sacrifices
you make for this crazy portability stay
tuned for that full review